welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
episode 5 today I spoke with Suzanne
banker Suzanne banker is an author
columnist and marriage and relationship
coach her work has appeared in countless
publications including Fox News the
Washington Examiner time USA Today and
the New York Post she also has her own
podcast the Suzanne Bankers show
Susannah is pretty heavily anti feminism
I'll have to have a pro feminist person
on the podcast if they'd agree just to
make the sides even but I do agree with
a lot of what Suzanne says not
everything but that could be because I'm
not wise enough yet who knows I've been
wrong before I think that her and her
books are a great resource for people
confused about roles and relationships
or women who aren't happy in
relationships and don't know why we talk
about having kids the green grass
syndrome and I touch on my troubles with
relationships relationships are not easy
folks they are not especially these days
so here we go
[Music]
Suzanne banker welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me Michaela I read
your book flipside of feminism when in
2011 when it came out I just I was
scrolling through Amazon my university
courses were being infiltrated by
feminism and I really wasn't interested
in it I had a number of friends who took
feminism courses like a lot of a lot of
my friends did my best friend did a lot
but I wasn't particularly interested in
learning feminism when I was you know
reading Homer through a feminist lens so
that started happening in my university
Concordia in Montreal and I was really
upset about it and bought a whole bunch
of books off of Amazon from both sides
so Betty Friedan's book other Pro
feminism books and then some books by
Warren Farrell and flipside of feminism
by you so I'm very excited I have the
opportunity to speak with you because I
really enjoyed the book that was the
only book I actually left an Amazon
review on out of 20 Pro and anti kind of
anti you know anti stereotypical
feminism books that alternative points
of view let's put that oh yeah let's do
that because I didn't find your book
your book was an anti woman at all if
anything it was Pro woman so it's funny
because you have one side that's you
know feminism saying that there for
women and then the other side also says
there for women like none of them are
anti women right right it's a completely
different way of viewing what a woman is
yeah it don't you yeah yeah same topic
but different slight slant completely
maybe not slant but different
perspective different perspective on the
same mission yeah yeah yeah one side I
find I find the like typical feminism
side that you learn about in university
and everything that's assuming men and
women aren't as different as I think
they are as the other as opposed to the
other side
absolutely 100% agree and as long as you
have the
that view you are going down a rabbit
hole of misery in my opinion to believe
that the sexes are equal as in the same
which is what the message is that they
pushed as in the same yeah so I thought
I thought we should start off by giving
people if you could give people a bit of
a background about who you are and books
you've written and how you decided to go
down that route yeah so um it's kind of
a long story but I wrote my first book
actually the first time I knew I had
sort of the writing bug was when I was
teaching my former life is in my 20s was
as a teacher I was at taught English
eighth grade ninth grade English and I
ended up leaving that world and and was
I was so horrified by what I saw in the
system and how it worked and I wanted to
tell people what was going on in the
classroom so I started what year on that
year was that that would have been that
would have been 93 94 95 yeah so all the
stuff that's going on in some way works
today but just political correctness
that's and this is what got me so much
into your dad because later which I was
so happy to have him on the scene
because the political correctness thing
was really it bit me way back then via
the education system and I was being
asked to do things I just simply
wouldn't and couldn't do and so
eventually I left and I wanted the world
to know what was going on in public
schools by just just laying out here so
here's what happened to me here's what
was going on in the classroom here's how
they dealt with it and I got pretty far
along with that book and that was up in
New York New Jersey at that time and I'm
from the Midwest which is where I am
currently and I my I was married then
and I got divorced I was going through a
divorce so I never finished that book it
kind of fell by the wayside because my
personal life took over so by the time I
picked up
another book idea I was remarried with
my first child and so that book same
idea you know going and against the
status quo the culture being very
counter or cultural in my approach and
message to in this case now motherhood
marriage raising kids so that book was
about the work of motherhood that was
supposed was supposed to be about and
how that how significant that work is
and that that's work that you're not
paid to do but it's vital to the health
of this nation and then children needs
you and here's how to here's how to meet
those needs and incorporate that into
the larger cultural narrative about
women and work and working mothers and
all of that now that was kind of at that
time the mommy wars were raging so I got
catapulted into this political slash
cultural place that I was not looking to
do when I wrote the book I just simply
wanted to support what mothers at home
were doing and that's when I got my
crash course in liberal / feminist media
bias I got thrown to the wolves yeah
big-time and I was so green I mean so
green I just wanted to write the damn
book you know so and be help you know
and help people so I got a crash course
and then after experiencing that and
getting a little you know trying to side
how to proceed from there I ended up
having a second child and then I kind of
disappeared to raise them take care of
them for about five years full-time and
I blog blogging started to become a
thing so I started to just mess around
on the computer that way during those
years and by the time I wrote the second
book which is flipside they were both in
school so that's where flipside came in
and then I got into the political realm
with that I mean I was happily I was
really going into the political piece of
the whole issue of motherhood and
marriage and feminism and all of that
and then after that after that sort of
played itself out for a few years I
decided that really my heart really
wasn't in the politics of it you know it
was very frustrating so when I watched
as the stuff happened to your dad
although at a totally different level
much higher level coming at him left and
right
I know that feeling I know it like
there's nobody like nobody's business I
mean I would get emails that said when I
ended up writing an article called the
war on men for Fox News that went viral
I that was 2012 I would get I was
slammed with emails from feminists and
one of them told me and that one of them
told me the subject the subject line
just read please kill yourself yeah
so I how was that on you like how was
how did you tolerate they the stress
with when that happens much differently
then than I do today today I can
honestly say that I feel so sorry for
people and it just rolls off my back but
that didn't come right away because I'm
a human yeah right I mean I am in so
initially it was like you know I just
you just can't believe the level of hate
and so it was quite an onslaught for
those for that year and it just sort of
takes a toll emotionally where
eventually in my case anyway I just sort
of became numb to it and I moved but I
did decide to move away from the
politics because I wanted to be more
helpful one-on-one with people in their
relationships and their lives and make
it so that I could eventually instead of
fighting feminism on this other level
like going to colleges and that kind of
thing um yeah I thought you know that's
not how that's not fun for me I don't
enjoy going up there and dealing with
with that it's just nothing really much
in it for me because I think they're so
tuned out but what ended up so I ended
up shifting to fighting that narrative
in individual lives which is why I now
do the coaching and the podcast which is
really where my focus is so that I can
talk one-on-one with people and really
affect change one by one yeah that's
probably that's probably a better idea
for you feels better all the way around
yeah yeah right the amount of stress
going into a college that my dad
experienced and having a whole bunch of
people absolutely
hate you like just the feeling you get
from that is really not easy to take I
don't know how some people like there
are some speakers that will do that
almost for fun and I don't know how they
do that could not agree more I've said
that for the last couple years I'm like
if you enjoy that sort of thing
have at it I did not and it took my
doing it once or twice to just say this
is not the road for me at all and and
just switching gears so that's why I
ended up now working more on a cultural
level and and working with people
one-on-one or in small groups as opposed
to going out and fighting you know the
masses and some giant way yeah yeah well
no this is good your book so anybody
who's listening I would really recommend
looking into Susan banker especially
flip side of feminism it was just it was
a fair book it was well-written I really
enjoyed it what what are the types of
people you mainly see is there one
category of people is it women that
gravitate towards you or men or couples
or so for a long time it actually there
was more men than women this is
interesting actually I'm going to say
that surprised by that probably not but
here's what's here's what I am support
not so much surprise but what's
interesting that went on for a couple of
years specifically after I wrote the war
on men
so that was an article for Fox News that
goes viral I go up to New York I'm on
the view I'm like all these crazy shows
and and Steven book Stephen Colbert
there spends five minutes mocking it and
it's just like this big thing well then
then I then my editor at the time wanted
me to quickly turn out an e-book with
that same title which I did after the
fact call also called the war on men and
that's just a short
a short ebook and as a result of that
and in the subsequent year or two I did
hear from more men obviously than women
but that's that was 2012-2013 so we're
now almost here we are 2020 20 right
that we are okay so for the past several
years I'd say three to four or five
years I would honestly say it's about
50/50 now I don't even know that it does
lean one way anymore because now what's
happening is I'm getting the people who
have lived long enough and many of whom
are married or out in the or they're in
a relationship and you're deciding
whether or not to get married but
they're old enough to have tried on this
sort of message that they've been
getting for years from the culture that
we talked about of men and women
basically being equal as in the same and
it's not working it's clearly not
working because hello we're not the same
so it doesn't work there's you can just
it's like forcing a rat's we're into peg
into a round hole all the way around and
so that's when I come in they're like
whoa I don't get my wife I don't get my
husband this isn't working
or if they were deciding whether or not
to get married like I had one client who
he was in his 30s and he was just sort
of building his new business and was on
his way but he was in love with this
woman who was 10 years ahead of him
maybe not 10 years but old 7 or 8 years
ahead of him a lot had already Bloodshy
to the top never topped out at her
business so she was making all the money
and she was around 40 so her ability to
conceive was not there and they were
trying to force this and he basically
wanted to know should I stay with her or
leave and find a young another woman who
needs me more financially essentially
that's what he was saying and who is
capable of having kids and so what do
you think my answer was basically you
know and there's not a lot of people who
are gonna tell you that they're just not
gonna say it because it's so it's so
countercultural and so taboo to say
these things that there are very few
people who are willing to say it so I
think that's what ends up being my thing
now is that I'm known to be that person
who just tell you how it is whether it's
popular or not because I want I want
your life to work I don't have agenda
that makes sense and the truth is still
there right like even if you sugarcoat
it that's not reality so it's not gonna
it actually and actually that's what
gets me going I mean that's that's why I
do what I do because I literally cannot
sit by when I know people are being lied
to for an agenda that has nothing to do
with you and your whole life is gonna be
totally ruined for some political agenda
and I can't just sit there and do
nothing I mean that's kind of what moves
me to do this work oh well good for you
um I asked my Instagram for questions
and I ki I have a whole bunch of them
that I think are gonna be really helpful
to people so I thought we could throw
some of those at you so I'm gonna start
with ones I'm like more interested in
that these are actually mine okay but I
think people will find them useful and
so I know from my experience with my
husband and just like a really short
background there is um we met online we
I really was not sure about him because
we come from different back backgrounds
like he's he's Russian and that was very
foreign and I was young like we met when
I was 23 and then when I was 24 I ended
up getting pregnant and I wanted to keep
the baby and we tried to make it work
and as soon as we had the baby my entire
life this is what happens my entire life
was pure baby and I was like I'm a bit
on the neurotic side too so I was like
obsessive and I know that that happens
to women too when they have a baby it's
all baby but it just completely killed
the romance in our relationship which
was kind of hard at the beginning anyway
because we hardly knew each other
um and I we ended up separating and
we're back together now thank God for
that and things are way better than they
ever have been because we spent a year
trying to figure out how to communicate
so that's a bit of my background but for
for people who are like struggling with
a relationship but trying to make it
work sex is a huge part of that and so
what's your opinion on like how to
maintain that how to maintain the
romantic part how often should you have
it
yeah it is such a big issue today I mean
I don't think it's that different than
it was 50 years ago except that there's
a lot more I think pressure to think
it's a post to be a certain way so I
just in fact I just wrote something
about how one of the things you don't
want to do and I'm specifying marry
sex here this is very important to
understand this is married sex because
basically what you just described is an
event that took place after you married
that completely threw you into another
place there's nothing unusual about that
that is one honey you are normal by
every stretch of the imagination so
understanding that your marriage is
gonna have these peaks and valleys with
the ideas over a long period of time and
not to get mired in something temporary
something temporary thinking that that
means something other than it does I
think that's a big key and I think that
has a lot to do with social media and
messages from the culture and from
Hollywood about what your sex life is
supposed to look like without any
discussion because it's not glamorous to
talk about the things that are
disruptive to that sex life like having
a baby but know that that's normal and
it's temporary and it will go away in
time go away meaning that temporary
inability to be the way you were before
baby is not permanent now I'm sure there
are people who if you get let it go on
too long you know you're literally not
having sex for a year - that's
problematic you can't do that because
then you will lose that that peace that
finds you but to understand that the sex
that you're gonna have before baby it's
totally different from the sex after
baby and then you throw another one in
the occasion into the equation and next
thing you know you know you're you're
you have to figure out how to create a
new normal let's put that way and
because we live in a culture that's so
sex saturated like everywhere you see it
if sex xx and there's this pressure or
idea that is supposed to be a certain
way and that may well that's not good in
any situation but it's not certainly not
good for married couples who are
building a family in those younger years
I think that's really important to know
so for example where my husband I are
almost empty nesters and we're very
excited about what happens when the kids
go away right we're waiting oh my gosh
like after 20 years you can actually
walk around
house naked if you want do you know how
freeing that's going to be right like
it's gonna feel like you're back I hope
like we're back in college kind of thing
so it's it's these are the stages of the
whole thing and it's there's just too
much angst and worry about the frequency
of it or this you know the kind of sex
you're having so that's one piece so
that's that you do need to of course I
actually think it was easier when I look
back sex was easier in those early years
a little bit later after you've got the
day routine established and the sleep
schedule and all of that when they're on
a schedule if they go to bed early we
always had early bedtime we always had
seven to ten to ourselves well once they
get older like throughout the teenage
years that's gone on we're almost it's
almost like we have roommates now so it
changed back again it was almost easier
when they were younger but yeah just
knowing that it adds and flows and not
to get mired down in what you see around
you because it's gonna make you feel
like you're doing something wrong I that
you know you're you're having inadequate
a relationship or sex life does that
person yeah that does so to win partly
partly when couples come to you and say
kids aren't involved and they're still
having you know sexual issues but
they've been together for a while is
there do you tell people to schedule it
or that there's an amount you should be
doing or do you not worry about
frequency
um I don't focus so much on frequency as
I do on setting the stage that will
allow it to naturally occur so for
example we'd go back we're gonna go back
to talking about the differences between
women and men now because that's what
this whole theme is kind of on is how
you want to be countercultural on your
approach men do not need to have the
stage set just so for sex they will have
it any way you want it anytime you want
it for the most part unless there's some
problem of some sort or some event you
know taking over in your life but
generally speaking they're ready to go
at the drop of a hat right it just
doesn't take much that's not the case
with women so especially with women who
are more type-a or high-strung or have a
tendency to get you know you know they
have a lot of anxiety or going crazy all
the time and moving fast and the way to
get that gal to be more interested in
sex from his perspective is to think
back to what it was like at the
beginning so when you remove those
distractions from a woman's plate and
you take your time and you set the stage
you're going to soften she's going to
soften quite naturally it's getting to
that it's how to get to that place when
you're in the midst of life right
because it's so easy to throw on some
candles and get dressed up and go out
for dinner or you know before you have
or but there's no one there's no kids in
the picture when there's kids in the
picture it's much harder to do that but
the idea is for men to know that she has
to she can't just do it that quickly I
mean she can but over time that's not
what either person wants for a long term
so the moat the thing that you can do to
get her into that whatever you can do to
get her into that place where everything
is off of her plate the more likely she
is to soften and then flip that for men
since they don't need that it's your job
when you're married to not always have
to have that stage set just so and to
just do it you know there's a lot of
research that shows that even if you do
it when you're not in the mood
not only will you not regret it
typically after the fact but it will
bring you closer just by the act of
doing it and so once again I go back to
the culture because when you see sex as
being something where where it work
where you're naturally feeling sexual
because this because all the all the
stars of aligned enough things in your
way real life isn't there and the way
then you have a tendency to think you're
supposed to be that way but in reality
sometimes you just have to do it and
when you do it you feel closer to the
person after the fact so don't so I tell
women not to wait until they're in the
mood because if they did that they might
never be in the mood and that's no good
so just do it and see how you feel
afterwards and then I tell men if they
want her to be more than just doing it
in that way they have to understand how
she operates and help to them there's
things that they can do to set the stage
so that she's more open to it I think
that's that's really good advice and
that's kind of the experience I've had
like mmm when I like when first was
dating obviously when you're first
dating you have that honeymoon period
and then I had a kid right away and was
like well I'm not interested in that at
all oh no it's the relationship and I
think that would know I that happens to
a lot of people but I think that was
also partly because I didn't like no
onder's my husband I didn't know him
very well
but I I do ii thee so you tell people to
negotiate and meet somewhere in the
middle like take her out on dates sure
try to unstress her and do stress yeah
do what you did in the honeymoon period
yes um now yeah I was just waiting to
say when no you go ahead go ahead
I was just gonna say that then sometimes
the men will get mad and say well why
should I have to go through all that
effort to get laid by my own wife
and I'm like well for the same reason
that I tell her sometimes to just do
what he whether she wants to or not yeah
you each have a role to play yeah so
meet somewhere in the middle that's good
advice
okay and then it would that would that
advice followed like trying to keep that
butterfly feeling that you get at the
beginning alive what's your
recommendation for how can people get
that back or is that just a honeymoon
period thing so I feel really strongly
about this I'm glad you brought this up
this is important
the answer is that short lived and will
not come back in that same way ever with
anyone no matter who you're with so one
of the statements I made and I think
when one of my most recent books is this
applies even if you married Brad Pitt
because believe it or not that will
there's no way to sustain that feeling
that you have during that honeymoon
period for a lifetime it's just if you
find somebody who actually feels that
way that's pretty remarkable because I
certainly cannot conceive of that there
is that the research has shown the day
to prove that there is a there is a
process and a road that a every
relationship will travel and that period
I do think young people get very caught
up in that again because of the
environment in which they're raised
where that is so valued that early stuff
that beginning part that there's no
understanding about longevity or how the
relationship gets deeper over time and
is and and then the sex part of that and
it doesn't have the same feeling but
that's not a worse feeling it's just a
different feeling that's very important
to understand the longer you spend with
somebody and the more you share and once
you've created a family that whole bond
is it's just not comparable to the
beginning stuff it's like I don't even
remember life before kids quite honestly
it doesn't matter not relevant because
of the growth that occurs after the fact
so I never think about you know I mean
if I were to divorce my husband today
and go out and find new men and
experience that that's short-lived that
will never ever last so to actually do
that with the idea that you're gonna
find something better with somebody else
is just a huge huge mistake and I think
I think it happens more often than we
know
I think people maybe even subconsciously
think there's something better out there
I talk a lot about the green grass
syndrome and what a huge pole it is on
people and how dysfunctional it is and
one of the best things you can do for
your marriage or relationship is to
literally never fall prey to that
syndrome because that can really screw
you up throughout a lifetime is to
constantly be looking over in your
neighbor's yard and thinking that
there's something better out there I
mean I think it's debilitating and I
think that it's a big thing for young
people once again because of the culture
in which the you know social media
you're always seeing people's lives and
thinking it's so much more exciting than
yours and that's such a trap to go down
I mean talk about a buzzkill for your
marriage right yeah yeah
comparing comparing who you're married
to day yeah you meet all the time in a
kind of way yeah definitely
okay the other the other thing I was
very interested in I always wanted to
have kids young but I'm very very type A
and like controlling want to run things
and very career-oriented and I had a
really difficult time trying to navigate
how much I should be doing baby wise
without feeling guilty basically just to
put it out there and how much of my
career I should put on hold or should I
feel bad for going back to work how do
you tell people to like navigate the
area of women in particular particularly
about like how how much they should be
working versus how much they should be
child rearing so that's a great question
and I haven't talked about in a while
because that's how I started that was
the first book that I wrote and I've
gotten so into the male-female dynamics
of relationships I haven't talked about
this issue a lot but I had do have very
strong feelings about it and it's pretty
hard lined I believe that children need
their mothers or at least one parent in
their lives in those early years and
that means that over the course of your
life there's going to be again I keep
going back to this epping and flowing
but there's a cease there are seasons
specifically in a mother's life where
your career and your other interests are
gonna have to take a backseat to you I
mean we know this this isn't rocket
science to your child as to how often
you know you know how much where is that
line everybody has to sort of figure
that out in their own lives but the
reality is in those early years for the
first five years basically you want to
be working almost 20 percent or less and
if I had to put a number on it with your
time now that that could a lot of that
depends on what the other parents doing
there are some people who tag-team right
where they're either of the babies
either with the mom or the dad or the
child depending on the age so there are
ways of doing this so for example for me
I quit working full time when I was
pregnant actually and I write it I write
it I'm a really good writer and
right in my wrote I was gonna say
blogged and then write I wrote and
writing obviously was something I could
do on my own I had no boss I could do it
when I could and when I couldn't I did
and it was wonderful it was a great
choice so that worked out but my plan
originally was to step out for a few
years and then go back into teaching
when the kids were in school and I ended
up never going back to teaching and just
sticking with writing but so there's so
I'm not sure exactly what you're asking
if you're saying how much is that what
you're asking how much for each kind of
at that time I had a number of questions
pop up and they're like you know for
instance there's a couple both of them
work so they're like you know early 30s
both of them have very successful
careers and they're trying to negotiate
well who puts the career on hold all
right how do we do this and this was
like the the woman was asking she was
like I'm not sure if I want kids and
like be putting my career on hold so
should he be taking part like so my most
recent book is called women who win at
love and that came out last October and
that book was all about how to figure
out the answers to those questions well
in advance this is very very important
if you want to get this down right which
nobody ever talks about the first part
of the book is before you get married
like book if it says before I do and the
second part of the book is after I do so
here's how you set up your life to
answer these questions so for example in
the in the before I do you're dating
someone you want to figure out then
ideally who's going to do what once your
entire life changes once the kids come
along decide that before you get married
that way you can start planning for that
financially professionally all the
decisions you need to make for that so
that's the ideal way of doing it if
you've missed the boat on that and
you're already married and you're in
this you know that's where so many
people are and unfortunately there's no
easy answer for that because you do get
yourself stuck because you made
decisions early on based on the fact
that you assumed two people were gonna
be in the workforce full-time year-round
your whole life going back to the whole
opening of this conversation
because no one talked you any different
you're supposed to be the same and so oh
my gosh all of a sudden you get married
and women start to think differently
I'll give you an example I just had a
coaching session the other day with a
woman who's a doctor and she is 39 and
just finally married a year ago and has
already had several miscarriages they're
open to adopting because she she
concedes that she missed the boat
probably and they're trying to iron out
now how that's all gonna go down you
know like even if she does even she does
concei or even if they do adopt that is
not the time to decide you've got
yourself in a huge pickle that's why I'm
so adamant about
not lying to women when they're younger
about what's gonna happen to them down
the road their hole for most people most
women not all there's always exceptions
to the rule but for most women their
priorities are gonna change dramatically
ten years down the line I want to help
set them up for what their lives are
going to look like ahead of time so that
they're not in that position once
they're in that position you know it's a
matter of trying to figure it out you
know I don't I mean I don't know that
particular story of that that woman's
but hopefully they had discussed this
somewhat ahead of time so they knew had
some general idea of what they would do
when they had a child do you find that
your generation has does not have those
competitions at all um prior to having
the babies I would I don't know I know
for me I always had conversations about
the future with whoever I was dating but
I'm pretty forward I would say a number
of my friends don't talk about it at all
and part of the problem my generation
has too are the women who want kids
especially in their 20s when it would be
a good time biologically to have kids
their significant others response is
well that'll ruin my life we should just
wait so just wait and it's like dude
this isn't this is her body kind of like
it's hard to have a baby it is hard to
be pregnant that's a huge sit like it's
a huge sacrifice for a number of years
and the payoff is immense but it's hard
and asking people to wait because you
want to like do more cocaine like well
that might just say something about
those people but yeah yeah that might
but but he represents what what the
culture has has taught for decades now
which is there is no hurry you have all
the time in the world
put marriage off put parenting off put
it all off as long as possible it's all
a big lie
and it's and it's done again for
political purposes they don't have your
best interests in heart there's a
and why your generation is being told
that and it has nothing to do with
what's good for you so you have to be
countercultural in your thinking and in
your mapping out your life if you want
to succeed that's basically my
underlying message to young women in
particular is if you are not
countercultural purposefully in your
decisions about life and love and in the
way you think you will very likely fail
because those the people who are calling
me 10 15 years down and they're in the
terrible situation so because they
followed along and saw it oh yeah that's
for later that's for later but I want to
address something you just said about I
can't remember how you just phrased it
but it's this idea that getting married
and having a family is the end of your
life
yeah the beginning yeah that's a huge
one is I won't be able to travel I won't
have any forego that now think about
even in your dad's in my age because
we're gonna roughly the same age and
then in our own parents age so I guess
your grandparents age what's different
about the way and I know the world was
totally different that's obvious but
what's different about the way those
other generations thought then then your
generation what do you think is well one
obvious difference and you can tell this
from old movies is you like in older
movies you fall in love with someone and
you're in love and you're like oh let's
create a family like that's the next
step it's like let's have a baby because
we're in love and let's bring a new life
into this world and now it's literally
oh my god don't get pregnant because a
baby will ruin your life if that's the
difference it's that's the difference
it's so huge it's it's beyond huge it's
such a major mind shift that everything
else falls away when you have that much
of a change in value system for what you
believe life is about right or what it
you know yeah it's it's such a
self-centered philosophy and so focused
on fleeting experiences and
fun as opposed to deep meaningful
relationships and values and building
communities and you know simple life at
home with your children and the joy that
that brings I mean just just compare I
mean so I'm a pretty you know some
people would say I'm pretty successful
person professionally right there is
absolutely nothing that I've done
professionally nothing that compares to
the feeling
of my first child we'll both my children
of course but the first time your baby
is laid upon your chest after you've
given birth there is absolutely nothing
like it in the world huh and to bring
that baby home and care for that baby
in those room and yes there's very
difficult times
I mean the colic the you know it's it's
messy for a while but once you get past
that part you have your life backing of
a schedule and that that beginning stuff
is gone
the joy and the satisfaction and a
fulfillment that comes from that there
is simply no in my opinion no comparison
and I don't think we hear enough about
that you know and I think it's important
to hear about that from people who have
been relatively successful in the
professional sphere so they can
understand that those because if you
hear it from one person who hasn't
experienced both you might question it a
little bit yeah yeah so I totally agree
straighting it's it's really frustrating
it's sad too because if you actually
think about it like you bring out a
really young baby out or even a toddler
or whatever everybody around smiles at
them right like this is actually
something that creates joy in everybody
and for some reason we're we're shown oh
like I don't know what the idea is that
people have it's just like you're gonna
have a screaming I guess they're worried
they're gonna have a screaming toddler
that they hate and that they're gonna be
stuck resentfully taking care of that
little human for you know two decades I
guess that's the fear okay so here's
what's funny about that there's some
truth to that you will be you might hate
the whole situation for a while let's
just face it it's gonna suck it might
suck I should say it's going to
everybody has a different experience but
I remember pulling my hair out I
remember thinking oh man oh my god
oh my god yeah but here's the ticket
here's the difference I think between
your generation in mind I really believe
this and even my own parents generation
it's understanding that this too shall
pass that it's temporary and it's
character-building and there's something
that's going to come out on the other
end
and you are going to be a much much
fuller happier mature being as a result
of this not the other way around I think
there's too much focus on what you lose
the contemporary is actually game
whether it's never looked upon as a game
but it is a game it's a tremendous game
like I can't even conceive of what my
life would look like if I did was not
married with children like I mean how
how boring I know a mine would look like
yeah yeah I mean I how many how many
days can you live just for yourself
every day I mean how could that and not
get old after a while I just wake up and
live for yourself day in and day out and
do whatever you want all the time I'm
sure some people want that but no I
certainly don't
I know what would happen to me if I
didn't have kids and I'm planning on
having more I have one right now it's
just two and a half is I would just work
all the time I would wake up at 7:00 in
the morning and I would go to sleep at
11:00 and I would work for my entire
life seven days a week like that well
let me give you a speak it's interesting
that you say that because I do not I
actually identify about that a little
bit I'll give you an example so I talked
about ABing and flowing in your seasons
of your life so I have a 20 year old and
a 17 year old and about a year ago my my
whole trajectory changed because I went
into this other phase where she went to
college and my son got his driver's
license and and and he had he uses our
car to get back and forth from school
into his job so he is entirely
self-sustaining and it's almost to the
point where I became an empty nester
before we technically are which will be
one more year where all of a sudden my
whole life was essentially my own again
from what you just described now I don't
work 7 them or eat 11 at night
because I love leaving early and going
home and being at my family like 4 or 5
but if I didn't have a family to go home
to I wouldn't I definitely would not I
would live exactly the way you just
described because I'm very much like you
I'm type-a I've got I think I've got
something to do I've got a mission I've
got things that I there
that I do outside of what I do at home
but it would be meaningless if I did not
have a home you know home to I mean a
home of a family to go home to a spirit
yeah yeah it'd be sad right like you
sometimes you need something to pull you
out of work for anyone who's listening
who's you know it's but particularly
women who are similar to us and who have
a career and want to continue working
like it's actually good for you to have
something that pulls you away from that
yes very much so and and I guess that's
what kept me in check all those years
because like I said I you know I was in
and then I was out for a number of years
and then I was back in part time and I
really honestly did not go to full time
really till about a year ago well like
when I say full time I mean get up take
a shower go to my office outside the
home come home at 4 or 5 and that's not
even for some people that's early
checking out early here in the Midwest
we like to check out early and because
we're very family focused but
I have not worked full-time in the
entire twenty years since I've had
children up until a year ago wow that's
cool okay let's let's let's change this
topic a little bit for people looking
this is another serious issue that I
think my generation has and maybe every
generation has but where do you go to
find a good mate because from my
experience a lot of people go to bars I
met Andre online which I would recommend
but even that is like is kind of scary
so what do you tell people if they're
looking for a mate and they don't know
where to start
where do you go what's up that's
actually my least favorite question
because a because I simply don't have
the answer I can only suggest what not
to do right I can tell you weird that I
can't tell you where to find him or her
I'd like to say off you go the grocery
store he'll be staying there in the
lettuce aisle you know and it's you know
that's silly salad buns yep stay out of
bars
that's number one at least upstander
bars what if you're searching don't
search for them there let's put it that
way because most people who are
family-focused aren't really frequenting
that's not their scene for the most part
I mean if you want somebody who's gonna
be a life partner just the chances of
your finding them in a bar are very
minimal you're more likely to find them
when you're not looking in some random
place as to the online thing I never
that was past my time so I've never ever
all I can tell you is what I read and
you might know more about than I do but
that does not seem like a good place
either because it completely changed is
the process of you know seeing each
other meeting face-to-face someone makes
a move the other one yeah like that
whole romance piece seems to be missing
from
from the equation and it's just a whole
I think you end up having to pick
someone based on what you're seeing it's
a visual thing right which you know the
visuals matter I mean even before doing
it that way people certainly choose
based on looks but I mean don't you have
to I mean you were you're reduced down
to listing your qualities on a piece of
paper right for online dating and that's
what you're reading so you're reading
about a person without seeing anything
about the nuances of him or her in terms
of his being it's it's not particularly
romantic I liked it because you could
screen and maybe I'm just strange I
liked it because I could go through like
400 people and screen out a whole bunch
of people and then I think there's a way
to do it like what I would do is meet
somebody you don't meet them at a bar
when you meet for the first time you go
and have a tea or a coffee
because then yeah you're sober and then
you have a conversation so I wouldn't do
very much back and forth online I just
screen a home but it's to find the pro
okay yeah that works and then go I can
see that yeah yeah that makes sense
so if we're talking about I mean I think
there's different variations of online
dating so if you're talking about
finding her just try to yeah
yeah and then you just yeah narrow it
down find the person and then begin the
process immediately and get ours
get off the phone and get into yeah I
could see that working pressure and then
making it more of a traditional dating
environment at that point yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I can only say we're you know
not to do it I can't say we're to do it
because you know that's fair it's
complicated I think for most people
they're gonna end up finding them at
work which is another complication it
can be a complication but I think that's
where a lot of people end up finding
people
um okay I'm I think another important
topic we could cover is a couple of
things how to argue and is arguing
healthy great question really great
question so I'm going to tell you my
personal story with this okay I grew up
on a high conflict household my parents
thought they lacked it was bad bad bad
bad
my husband is a product of divorce and
grew up in not a conflict or in the
household but it was just sort of in the
air like you like the tenseness and it
was not loud and conflict ridden so it
was almost like it was quiet and all of
a sudden one day I'm leaving which is a
whole nother set of problems talk about
extreme upbringing center in terms of
that so I believe we each come with us
to the marriage table with some idea
about how to manage conflict and then
some does that mean maybe conflict
avoidance right depending on what they
saw growing up and it got into their
skin you know like whatever they saw
they either repeat or they try to avoid
it but they don't know how to avoid it
so they don't know how to go about it
and I think there are a lot of people
out there who think that if they don't
address something that it will just go
away when your member works never never
never
not talking about something doesn't make
it go away so that's not an option but I
think it's important to understand that
fighting slash cons I prefer to call it
conflict is absolutely inevitable it's
in everybody's marriage whether you see
it or not so it's really important to
know again going back to the not
comparing thinking that you know some
relationship if it's really good looks
just think of one that you know of that
you think is really good don't make the
mistake of thinking that there's not
conflict behind the scenes because there
is so to answer your question and the
existence of conflict isn't the problem
in fact if anything you should have some
conflict cuz it really wouldn't make to
me if you're not having conflict you're
avoiding it and that's worse than
addressing it
so so knowing that you're going to have
it from the get-go is important so that
when it does happen you don't think
there's something weird about you or
that that's not normal because it is
normal okay so then the question is how
to address it right so I'm very big on
huge on always communicating your
feelings when you have them yeah
something I just realized - yeah yeah
how did you just realize it what
happened well it wasn't just now but in
the last like since I got back with
Andre I've realized that those feelings
like if something happens you're in a
situation and you're viscerally
uncomfortable with it say something let
the other person know because just
saying you know what well maybe I'm
uncomfortable but really I shouldn't be
so I'm in the wrong so I won't say
anything is a really bad idea and it
took me like two years to figure out
that even if I can move even if I think
I'm in the wrong and that I shouldn't
say anything I should still bring it up
and tell the other person now there's a
there's another added component of that
though and that is so there's three
components so the first is to recognize
that the conflict is normal and
inevitable and in every single marriage
even the ones that you think are perfect
be eat make sure you address things when
they come up do not stuff them down
because they'll come out later they
always do and then the seed is you have
to address it properly though that's the
other thing
so why you don't want to suppress it
there's a way to do it to be heard and a
way to do it that's gonna repel and that
that gets pretty complicated so I are
you familiar with my book the alpha
females guide the more reason to read
that one No okay so I will next okay so
this you need this book because this is
the book I love to talk about the most
because it's hand-in-hand with what I do
in my coaching sessions so and if you
don't know this I should get this out
now because it's kind of significant the
most significant thing I've done the
last several years it's called the alpha
females guide to men and marriage and
it's part memoir and it opens talking
about my parents and their high conflict
marriage specifically my mother and her
controlling and critical ways and I was
concerned that I had adopted
some of that because I am type-a and
because I am controlling or at least I
was and I certainly am in my day life
and I felt like I didn't want it to
bleed over into my relationship and home
life and so and my marriage rather and
while so so so so my husband and I
struggled and it took me a long time to
figure out to figure it out basically
like what why was this not working how
was I contributing to this and I ended
up writing this book and and so it's
like a self-help book but it's also part
memoir in it and it has tons of examples
and talks about my marriage it talks
about my transformation from being well
I labeled it at the alpha females guide
to men and marriage is basically you
know type a Type B alpha beta that's the
words I use in the book but basically
that if you're a hard-charging
strong-willed woman that you have to
find a way to keep that out of your
marriage and your relationship if you
want to be successful in that realm yeah
and you can do that all you can do that
all day long during the day there's a
time and a place for that and I'm not
saying it's a bad personality
it is my personality I get it but it
will not work in your marriage if you do
not figure out how to let go
surrender cut back from that there's a
lot of techniques in there there's a lot
of examples and there's a lot of stories
about what I what kind of thing I'm
talking about you know not meaning to
have the last word and then taking into
account the differences between men and
women and how that factors in to the
equation when it comes to conflict so
basically it's a book about how to stop
having any conflict in your life or keep
it at a minimum because you'll never
stop it entirely or when you do confront
it how to get the most out of it right
how to make it work for you instead of
against you and so for people like you
and me who have our personalities we're
the ones who need that book more than
anything like my daughter is not like me
personality wise so she will never need
this book but people like you and I do
yeah I think that definitely sounds like
something I need I've had a hard time
well I like to be in
I'd like to be the dominant one and a
lot of the issues I had with former
relationships as I was the dominant one
and I don't really want to be the
dominant one like it's something I think
I want but I don't really want that so
that's the number one theme of all of my
coaching sessions it got to the point
where wow this is a major sociological
phenomenon with women being in these
leadership positions or being more
dominant or being type-a or whatever you
want to call it and the relationships
are not working because what you want
from a man is not to control him you
just don't you want so the whole book is
about basically have a let go of control
and why you need to be in control so
it's much more about looking into you
and your needs and understanding
yourself better and then understanding a
man and how he operates and then letting
go of your need to control and then
accepting men for what they need from
you and understanding that symbiosis and
how once you do finally let go you will
have that relationship that you dreamed
of but it's you're holding on too tight
that's gonna keep him from being the
strong man you need him to be and this
is going on left and right I mean it's
almost like to the point where I said to
my husband I just do this full-time for
because every person who gets with me
it's the same dynamic it's on repeat
interests and then but what and they're
really bad in a really extreme situation
that is really bad that I've written a
lot about is when she's the breadwinner
and he's not bringing home any money now
that's a whole nother that takes it to
another level I've never experienced
that but I've experienced it through
these people who are who are
experiencing it and it's completely
ruined the sex completely ruined their
marriage and they don't understand why
because I've never had anybody tell them
that's not gonna work that's not
actually what you're attracted to yeah I
know and that's why well Fifty Shades of
Grey that's why Fifty Shades of Grey was
such a bet bestsellers because women
actually want somebody who can take care
of them right and who's strong and
that's just evolutionarily how we would
have like a family that stays safe is
you want somebody stronger than you so
they can protect you but then if you're
you know type-a or whatever you want to
call it then you also want to be in
charge here you feel like you want it
but you don't you don't you think you do
it's really
demonic you playing game almost you
think you do yeah and it's about its I
mean let's call it what it is it's about
trust it's about trust and when you have
somebody that you can trust and there's
no reason for you to not trust him like
he hasn't done anything to make you not
trust I mean it's perfectly trustworthy
then the issue lies within you not him
right the and that's something that once
you shift that thinking then you end up
having what you ultimately do want but
you you're keeping yourself from with
having that wall up it's very
complicated I mean it's it isn't it
isn't like the solution is easy but the
reasons why people women in particular
are that way is complicated because I
think that goes way back to what they
learned growing up and what they learned
from the culture and it's a it's it's a
game changer to to let go of all that
and that's literally what I do every day
with people helping dude that is so cool
yeah well we've addressed a whole bunch
of problems I had particularly you know
trust being in charge like all that so
I'm definitely going to read your newest
book I'd be very interested in having a
copy of that but I think we should wrap
it up that was a really interesting
conversation and thank you so much for
coming on my podcast it's really cool
cuz like I said I bought your book in
2011 and I greatly enjoyed it so this is
very awesome I'm so glad I hope that
moves you away from the feminist mindset
and trap for ever
oh I wasn't even I was never in it I
mean I had my dad as a father I gave him
all my books is funny too cuz he was
kind of involved in the whole political
correctness thing but when I moved I
moved back home because I got really
sick and I gave him like 30 books on
feminism and that just like ramped up
his irritation at the whole what was
going on in the universities and anyway
so that was very funny where can people
find you online so my website is just my
name so Suzanne su zan any venker ven
kar dot-com and literally houses
everything you would ever need at that
site well our way to highly recommend
anybody listening men or women I yeah to
yeah check out the web counter books and
I have a podcast the Suzanne banker show
which is still somewhat in its infancy
it was since last middle of last year
and I know you're gonna be on in a few
weeks so I would encourage any of your
listeners to absolutely listen to the
Suzanne banker show it's great stuff
it's all about thinking outside the box
counter culturally and and she's Advan
Kirsch a bit Susan yeah so okay yep I
was originally that out too okay awesome
it was a great podcast I was originally
a radio show that's how it became oh
yeah it was a radio show with the
podcast component and then the radio
show was bought out so I grabbed my
producer and kept the podcast and went
somewhere else to record and come the
name yeah cool well thanks again for
coming on thanks for having me
[Music]
you